chers collègues sans plus attendre nous
allons
entendre toujours dans le cadre de la
préparation de notre rapport sur
l'adaptation des modes d'action de
l'État dans les outres mers le général
Claude Pelou commandant du Service
Militaire Adapté je rappelle que le
Service Militaire Adapté créé en
1961 est un dispositif militaire
d'insertion socio-professionnelle
rattaché à la direction générale des
outr-mers et qu'il s'adresse aux jeunes
ultramarins de 18 à 25 ans éloignés de
la qualification et du marché de
l'emploi ce dispositif apporte une
réponse ciblée à l'exclusion au chômage
à la désocialisation et à l'ilétrisme
qui s'visse particulièrement parmi les
jeunes ultramarins c'est aussi un
exemple souvent cité d'adaptation
réussie nous sommes donc très heureux de
vous accueillir général et impatient de
vous entendre sur les facteurs de ce
succès après votre exposé liminaire sur
les spécificités de ce dispositif et ses
excellents résultats nos rapporteurs
Philippe Bas et Victorin Lurel vous
interrogeront sur les aspects plus plus
précis puis nos autres collègues
poseront leurs questions à leur tour
s'il le souhaitent je vous cède la
parole merci
beaucoupadame merci beaucoup madame euh
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames et
messieurs donc je suis le général Claude
Pelou je commande le service Militaire
Adapté depuis le 1er août 2021 euh
préalablement à cette affectation j'ai
servi comme tout officier de l'armé
terre à la fois en unité opérationnelle
et puis en administration centrale mon
cœur de métier étant
plutôt les le suivi des programmes
d'armement où j'ai exercé pendant une
petite dizaine d'années à la fois à la
section technique dans l'armé terre mais
également dans des unités particulières
comme le commandement des opérations
spéciales je suis
j'ai été chef de corps du SMA de la
Guadeloupe de 2009 à 2011 ce qui me vaut
le plaisir d'être aujourd'hui le général
commandant ses formations dans les
territoires et
départements très rapidement donc vous
l'avez dit à l'initiative du de Michel
Debray alors Premier ministre et sur
proposition du général Nemo le service
militaire adapté a été créé aux
antiguyan en
1961 il doit alors répondre à trois
attentes particuli
et politique la première c'est intégrer
des jeunes dans la nation la seconde
c'est accompagner le développement et la
valorisation des territoire et enfin
c'est répondre aux enjeux démographiques
pour un rééquilibrage entre les
département des Antilles où la
population s'accroit et celui de la
Guyane qui était à l'époque considéré
comme sous-peuplé donc le plan Desmo
s'inscrit dans une logique
d'incorporation des jeunes du des
territoires
pour un appel de 24 mois il assure donc
à ces jeunes appléantis aiguyanis une
formation professionnelle et
général le futur service doit également
s'insérer dans les territoires par des
travaux d'intérêt au profit de cette
communauté tout en modulant les tout en
se s'adaptant pardon aux réalités
locales ce qui fait encore la force
aujourd'hui de du service militaire
adapté le général Nemo avait pour
objectif de donner une
occupation et une formation à une
jeunesse désœuvré et prête à subir les
influences les plus
pernicieuses donc depuis sa création en
1961 le SMA n'est cessé de se
développer avec quelques malgré les
rétisences initiales et c'est donc
déployé à la Réunion en 1965 en
Nouvelle-Calédonie en 1986 à Mayotte en
1988 puis en Polynésie française en
1989 avant de se créer un centre de
formation du service militaire adapté à
périgux qui peut accueillir les jeunes
ultramarins en complément de formation
dans le terire dans le territoire
hexagonal c'est donc bien la seule
formation en dehors des territoires et
départements
d'outram en 96 lorsque le président
Chirac a décidé de suspendre le service
national à la demande des élus
ultramarins il a été décidé de maintenir
le service militaire adapté dans les
territoires parce que il y avait des
enjeux particuliers en particulier pour
la jeunesse des
territoires comme pour les communauté
locale donc la forme choisie a été le
volontariat et donc la transition s'est
faite entre 97 et 2000 date à laquelle
nous n'avons accueilli plus que des
volontaires
3000 étaient accueillis jusqu'en 2009
date à laquelle le président Sarkozi a
souhaité doubler les effectifs du
service militaire
adapté pour permettre justement à plus
de jeunes de passer dans notre
dispositif et s'insérer dans la vie
économique des
territoires ça a été atteint pour la
première fois en
2017 et depuis nous tangentons les 6000
malgré la crise covid par
exemple
aujourd'hui nous sommes sur un plan
particulier qui s'appelle ambition 2030
qui regroupe deux plans SMA 2025 et SMA
2025 plus qui prévoit notamment la lutte
contre le décrochage scolaire les
violences faites aux femmes on accentue
également les compétences de base savoir
lire
écrire et surfer en sécurité bien
entendu et la possibilité pour tout tous
les volontaires d'être présentés au
permis de conduire car on sait combien
c'est un sésam pour aller à
l'emploi l'organisation générale du SMA
vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure c'est
sous la double tutelle du ministère de
l'Intérieur et des outr mè et du
ministère des
armées c'est c'est l'arrêté du 21
janvier 2021 portant organisation du SMA
qui le précise et le commandement du
service militaire adapté est rattaché à
la Direction générale des outres mèes
par application de article D
3222-191 et suivant du code de la
défense le commandement du service
militaire adapté est si placé pour
emploi sous les ordres du ministre
chargé des outres mè il est dirigé par
un officier
général dénommé commandant du service
militaire adapté et qui donne les
directives techniques fixe les objectifs
à atteindre et veille à leur bonne
exécution composé de SEP formations
administratives et d'un centre de
formation dans les AG le SMA propose une
réponse ciblée au chômage à la
désocialisation à
l'illétrisme et répond au besoins de
qualification des jeunes ultramarins de
nationalité française entre 18 et 25
ans composé de plus de 1300 cadres des
armées ce qui représente à peu près 1 %
des effectifs de l'armée de terre en
particulier et quelques personnels civil
d'active et de réserve les régiments du
Service Militaire Adapté propose trois
types de statuts sous le la base du
volontariat le premier des statuts est
le volontaire technicien il est proposé
à des jeunes diplômés qui souhaitent
pouvoir valoriser leur expérience
professionnelle car nous leur offrons
une première expérience professionnelle
en milieu
militaire ce contrat initialement d'une
année peut-être renouvelé jusqu'à quatre
fois ce qui permet de remplir un peu le
CV du du jeune avant qu'il ne trouve un
emploi dans les territoires ou dans
l'Hexagone la deuxième catégorie est
bien l'essence même du Service Militaire
Adapté sont les volontaires
stagiaires euh qui viennent donc suivre
une formation professionnelle qui est
différenciée en fonction du niveau
scolaire de 6 à 12 mois vous avez des
formations titrantes qui sont qui
contrôlé par les préfectures ou par un
certificat de qualification
professionnelle nécessite une formation
plus longue que certaines qui ne sont
que des remises à niveau l'objectif
étant que le jeune ben retrouve le geste
technique avant de pouvoir retourner à
l'emploi et enfin des volontaires jeunes
cadet ça se fait en étroite
collaboration avec les
rectorats ça s'adresse à des jeunes de
16 à 18 ans qui sont en décrochage
scolaire l'objectif étant donc de les
euh remettre sur les rails 290 jeunes
l'année dernière 231 jeunes pardon
l'année dernière sont passés au sein de
cette des des formations pour suivre le
module
de retour à l'éducation nationale 90 %
d'entre sont effectivement retournés à
l'école et sont passés dans la classe
supérieure bon l'ensemble de de ces
jeunes participe à donc à l'amélioration
des compétences locale en réduisant les
inégalités territoriales et en
favorisant l'inclusion des jeunes femmes
puisque nous avons environ 30 % de notre
effectif qui est représenté par la
population féminine avec des disparités
entre Mayotte et le le Pacifique où on
tangente plutôt vers les 42 43 % de
jeunes
femmes chaque incorporé se voit orienter
en fonction de son niveau d'ilétrisme
puisque chaque jeune en arrivant passe
un test qui s'appelle le test qui a été
conçu en lien avec l'Agence Nationale de
Lutte contre
l'ilétrisme soit vers des filières
courtes soit des filière longue de 6 à
12 mois comme je
l'évoquais à l'issue d'une première
phase qui est une phase de formation
militaire initiale qui dure 2 mois il
est orienté vers une filière
professionnelle il est aussi accompagné
parce que nous voulons nous avons une
formation
complète par un accagnement
médicopsychosocial pour lever les freins
à
l'insertion pour les problèmes que vous
connaissez pour le ceux qui sont les
plus éloignés de nos
repères la formation qui est autant que
de possible individualisé comporte
plusieurs phases mais qui sont souvent
imbriqué la formation professionnelle
une formation civique et citoyenne une
remise à niveau scolaire en français et
en mathématique
des modules de lutte contre l'érisme et
l'éleectronisme et puis bien entendu la
présentation au permis de conduire qui
est le brevet militaire de conduite mais
qui est transformable en permis B et une
qualification qui est donnée à
l'ensemble des jeunes qui est de la
formation de sauvteur socouriste au
travail
elle répond donc elle repose
essentiellement sur trois piliers le
premier c'est le savoir-être qui se fait
essentiellement grâce à la
militarité tout au long de la
formation le savoir-faire qui est à la
fois le geste technique en affirmation
professionnelle et la remise à niveau
scolaire à ce titre nous bénéficions
d'un renfort de 40 professeurs de
l'éducation nationale un par formation
par unité
élémentaire et puis le savoir deevenir
qui permet de préparer le jeûne à la vie
civile à l'emploi grâce aux techniques
de recherche d'emploi grâce à ce module
la
MPS pour ceux qui arriveraient dans nos
rangs sans qualification aucune les
régiments font passer aux jeunes après
les modules de remise à niveau le
certificat de formation générale qui est
le premier niveau
scolaire détenu les modules de technique
de recherche d'emploi d'appui à la
construction d'un projet professionnel
permett donc aux jeunes volontaires de
trouver un premier emploi ou une reprise
de formation à la sortie du positif
puisque nous donnons un certain nombre
de qualifications qui correspondent
éventuellement à un premier module d'un
CP d' un beep et viennent soit dans les
centres de formation pour adultes dans
les territoires poursivre leur formation
soit dans l'Hexagone à Périgueux dans
une formation
spécifique chaque territoire ou
département est spécifique chaque
filière professionnelle est adapté au
contexte socio-économique du territoire
et bien sûr grâce au Conseil de
Perfectionnement présidé par par le chef
de corps les et le le préfet les besoins
des territoires sont étudiés pour
modifier les formations professionnelles
au
profit du territoire il est bien évident
que vous ne n'aurez pas en Guyane les
mêmes formations que celle de la
Polynésie française nous avons des
pilotes lagonnaire à tbou et ivaa nous
avons plutôt des accompagnateurs en
forêt pour le parc national guyanais euh
sur le sur le département de la
Guyane la géographie impose aussi
d'avoir des compagnies dites isolées ou
éloignées donc isolé vous en avez deux
qui fonctionnent à 100 % avec le et puis
une 3oe qui a été demandé par le
Président de la République au mois de
juin de juillet 2021 donc vous avez les
trois polynésiennes en fait ivaoa dans
les Marquises tbou dans les Australes et
aujourd'hui à dans les toitmoutou
il bénéficie d'un statut
particulier parce que ils ont un statut
dit de fixer c'est-à-dire que le
développement économique du de leur Atol
ou il n'étant pas celui de Tahiti et
bien les jeunes retournent dans leur
dans leurs îles mais ont une formation
qui leur permet de s'installer d'y
rester ou de trouver un emploi ou de le
développer c'est un peu le que nous
avons fixé avec la nouvelle compagnie à
où nous avons eu de cesse de réfléchir
sur la préservation de
l'environnement la l'autonomie
alimentaire et l'autonomie énergétique
et donc on leur donne les modules
nécessaires pour qu'ils puissent ensuite
dans leurs îles etatol proposer
les leur formation dans les communes
pour aider
à à améliorer le
quotidien le SMA
localement dépend en fonction du
territoire du département du préfet ou
du haut
commommissaire qui préside je vous l'ai
dit le conseil de perfectionnement qui
est ensuite validé ici à Paris par le
directeur général des
outramers
et
ce
localement le référent du chef de corps
est le préfet il n'est mis à disposition
des armées que sur demande
particulière soit demande de concours
soit demande de réquisition du préfet ou
de l'Admiral ou général commandant la
zone les forces armées localement en
particulier en cas de catastrophe
naturelle bon on entretient bien entendu
des liens interministériels avec les
armées puisque nous travaillons nous en
arrivons et puis nous y
retournerons avec le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale j'en ai parlé
puisque nous avons 40 professeurs
détachés et le ministère du Travail en
particulier lorsqu'il a fallu aligner le
traitement des volontaire sur le contrat
emploi jeune puisque le montant versé
par le contrat emploi jeune était
supérieur au traitement proposés aux
jeunes volontaires et bien naturellement
ils allaient plutôt vers le CEJ que de
venir dans les formations
administratives du Service Militaire
Adapté nous avons deux instances
particulières le comité interministériel
de coordination du Service Militaire
Adapté présidé coprésidé par le général
chef de la division emploi de
l'état-major des armées mon mon
représentant et bien entendu par le
délégué général pour les le directeur
général pour les outre maire le préfet
Jacob pour les les grandes orientations
du SMA et puis nous nous avons un comité
d'orientation stratégique qui se réunit
chaque année qui nous donne les
orientations où vous avez là l'ensemble
des acteurs que j'ai évoqué le dgfp le
DG SCO bien sûr l'état-major des armées
le comsma et le
dgom qui préside avec là encore le le
général Mabin qui est
le chef de la division emploi de
l'EM on a bien entendu un certain nombre
de conventions localement à la fois avec
les collectivités
territoriales mais également avec un
certain nombre d'autres acteurs
économiques l'objectif étant pour nous
d'avoir le plus grand nombre d'appuis
pour trouver à l'issue d'une formation
professionnelle dans nos formations
administratives un emploi pour le
jeune
alors vous l'avez dit nous sommes
souvent cités comme étant une réussite
des politiques publiques
outreem bon d'abord elle est portée par
ses excellents résultats le fruit de
plus de 60 ans d'investissement et des
finalement de connaissance du dispositif
dans les territoires et départements
d'outremè si
je bien souvent les formations du
Service Militaire Adapté sont plus
applaudis que les forces armées le jour
du 14
juillet ce qui prouve que la population
est attachée à ce dispositif raison
aussi pour laquelle il perdure aujour'hu
parce que les élus ont souhaité que ça
continue donc
nous nous sommes suivis sur un certain
nombre d'indicateurs stratégiques
euh en particulier l'insertion
socio-professionnelle l'année dernière
donc les les résultats 2023 sont quasi
similaires à ceux de 2022
83,6 % des jeunes qui sont passés par le
dispositif du SMA ont trouvé un emploi
dont 2 tiers
d'un emploi durable c'est-à-dire soit un
CDI direct soit un CDD supérieur à 6
mois et pour le relica ce sont
essentiellement ou des des poursuites de
formation à l'extérieur ou ce que l'on
appelle des sorties positives c'est donc
des des contrats inférieurs à 6 mois
j'ai un devoir enfin mes chefs de corps
ont un devoir de suivi des jeunes à 6
mois de leur sortie pour savoir ce
qu'ils deviennent
B vous savez que nous ne pouvons pas
manipuler les chiffres une fois qu'ils
sont sortis mais dans les études qui ont
été
conduites 5 ans après 80 % des jeunes
qui sont passés par le SMA et qui
avaient un emploi en sortant sont pour
80 % de la classe d'âge considérée
toujours à l'emploi alors ce ne sont pas
forcément les mêmes qu'au départ mais
globalement on reste sur ces chiffres
là
bon les facteurs qui expliquent la
réussite c'est je vous l'ai dit les
facteurs historique pour
commencer parce qu'on fait partie
intégrante des territoires et
départements et que la plupart de nos
volontaires ont souvent de la famille
qui est passé et qui au regard de leur
expérience voyant leurs frères sœurs
cousins cousin galérer un peu si je puis
me permettre et ben les Orient vers le
SMA parce qu'ils savent que derriè
un minimum de 8 jeunes sur 10 sort avec
un
emploi le caractère militaire a une
plusvalue certaine c'est-à-dire que ce
que je peux faire les établissements de
l'AFPA ne peuvent pas c'est que le
contrat du jeune qui est un contrat
militaire de
volontaire permet d'avoir une certaine
autorité lors des formations
professionnelles et le jeune
est appuyé cont cond épaulé tutoré pour
aller jusqu'au bout de sa formation
sachant que le cadre militaire qui est
là et qui est le formateur n'a pas
vraiment d'horaire à donner à ce jeune
on n'est pas contraint au 1600 heur de
formation professionnel pour obtenir le
diplôme s'il faut passer plus de temps
pour le jeune et ben on passe plus de
temps pour le jeune et la journée
commence tôt peut finir tard mais
l'objectif est bien que le jeune en
sortant et un emploi
donc les les chefs de section qui sont à
la manœuvre et qui encadre ces jeunes on
inculqu les CIN règles de base que l'on
appelle les règles d'or comme vivre dans
collectivité en internat travailler pour
réussir savoir travailler en équipe et
en sécurité rendre compte en particulier
et bien entendu la militarité leur
redonne un peu le goût de l'effort
puisque ils ont pu
aussi
abandonner les activités physiques ou
l'envie de se véau pour aller
travailler donc chaque dans chaque
régiment
pardon les le parcours de formation est
ainsi borné par la militarité et puis
ensuite il s'agit au de de pouvoir
travailler sur le volontaire dans sa
globalité le savoir-faire de base
professionnel hein puisque bien
évidemment les entrepreneurs connaissent
le niveau de sortie des jeunes qu'ils
reçoivent et appliquent bien
le droit du travail avec la formation
tout au long de la vie et il préfèrent
avoir des jeunes finalement bien éduqués
respectant les règles de base de leur
entreprise plutôt que d'être obligé
d'attendre à 10h du matin l'éventuel
jeune garçon ou jeune fille pour venir
travailler
euh ce
parcours de formation
professionnelle avec des militaires et
des professeurs à donc proué son
efficacité
aujourd'hui la finalité du service
militaire adapté c'est bien la capacité
à faire grâce à un apprentissage
contextualisé une pédagogie fondée sur
la mise en situation et la qualité du
parcours qui est proposé est adapté à la
capacité du jeune qui suit le D
parcours on peut bien entendu dupliquer
ce ce dispositif bon nous le taux
d'encadrement est à peu près de 20 % 1
pour
5 avec une certaine discipline ce qui
fait notre force puisque on peut
sanctionner mais on s'est aussi
récompenser et puis pour nous il semble
il nous
semble ma enfin prioritaire que les
jeunes soient
pensionnaire parce que ça permet de les
avoir au quotidien sous
l'autorité des du personnel militaire et
donc de de lui garantir une certaine un
certain rhythme de vie et un certain
cadre pour continuer à
progresser bon je je l'ai dit he en 96
lorsque le président Chirac a décidé de
suspendre le service national nous
sommes passés sur la base du volontariat
donc c'est c'est la deuxième force du
SMA c'est-à-dire que ceux qui viennent
ne viennent pas parce qu'on les a appelé
ou parce qu'on les a forcés mais bien
parce qu'ils veulent s'en
sortir
euh donc le jeune en fonction de la
filière professionnelle qu'il a suivi
peut bien entendu rentrer directement
dans la vie active parce qu'il est
titulaire d'un titre professionnel ou
d'une qualification professionnelle
particulière
ou sans celle-ci il a réussi à
convaincre grâce à une période
d'adaptation à l'entreprise le
l'employeur qui le prend et lui fait
passer les qualifications nécessaires au
cours de son appartenance à l'entre
entreprise ou alors il poursuit une
formation ou sur le territoire ou dans
l'Hexagone ici à Périgueux bien entendu
en partenariat avec laadom certaines
formations ne sont pas dispensées sur
les territoires ou à Périgueux et bien
entendu le la Dom prend le relais pour
que le jeune puisse aller suivre une
formation professionnelle complémentaire
dans l'Hexagone dans un centre
adapté les politiques publiques doivent
à mon sens et prioritairement coordonner
les actions des différents organismes de
formation ce qui n'est pas forcément
toujours le cas parce qu'il peut y avoir
des compétitions entre organismes de
formation La formation est un gros
gâteau si je puux me permettre qui peut
rapporter gros et donc chacun tire un
peu la couverture à lui justement pour
que derrière son chiffre d'affaires soit
meilleur notre objectif c'est pas que
notre chiffre d'affaires soit meilleur
je n'en ai pas mais que notre taux de
réussite et d'insertion soit le plus
élevé
possible pour ce qui est de la gestion
des ressources humaines donc je vous
l'ai dit nous appartenons pour beaucoup
à l'armée de terre sur les 1300
cadres vous avez à peu près 1000 cadres
qui sont originaires de l'armée de terre
les autres proviennent ou du service de
santé des armées puisque je ne suis pas
embasé comme dans les formations
administratives de l'Hexagone je suis
donc propre je suis maîre de
propriétaire pardon de mes propres
soutiens alimentation restauration et
santé j'ai un service constructeur
également ce qui n'est pas le cas des
formations administratives de l'Hexagone
puisqu'il y a un service
dédié donc ce personnel est mis à
disposition par les directions des
ressources humaines de l'armé TER et des
directions et services ce sont des
cadres en général matures puisque il ils
arrivent avec des fonctions de chef de
section ou de chef de service
et
aujourd'hui il ne faut pas que nous
descendions en dessous du volume qui est
le nôtre c'est-à-dire d'un ratio
d'encadrement de 21 à 22
%. bien entendu aujourd'hui il y a de
pour multiplier le dispositif dans
d'autres îles et àol il y a la limite
bien entendu de ce que les armées
peuvent faire parce que le chef
d'état-major des armées a une enveloppe
contrainte et il prend sur cette
enveloppe pour donner au services
militair
adapté par ailleurs mais ça ne dépend
pas du SMA vous avez un certain nombre
de sousofficiers ou d'officiers
originaires des territoires qui sont
affectés dans les territoires pas
forcément dans leur territoire mais ça
c'est fonction des administrés bien
entendu et des postes à pourvoir
voilà aujourd'hui nous sommes sur un
plateau de recrutement à 6000
bénéficiaires ça semble
être ce que nous savons faire de
mieux la crise covid et la difficulté
que générait à la foit la
vaccination obligatoire contre le covid
qui était imposée par
le schéma vaccinal des armées mais
également l'alignement sur le CEJ qui a
généré quelques difficultés de
recrutement n'existe plus aujourd'hui ça
a été tout a été levé en août
2023 et donc la tendance du recrutement
nous laisse à penser que nous devrions
atteindre cette année de nouveau le
chiffre de 6000 bénéficiires
5000 un peu plus de 5800 pour
l'année
2023 ce qui est quand vous connaissez
les difficultés des 8 premiers mois avec
la l'obligation vaccinale et
l'alignement du CEJ et l'opération
womouchou à Mayotte qui nous a privé
d'un volume de recrutement puisque le
quartier avait été dévolu au à des
escadron de jeendarmerie nous sommes
finalement sur le trait si je puux me
permettre alors pourquoi je vous dis que
6000 est ce que nous savons faire et qui
risque de rester ce que nous faisons de
mieux ben parce que à l'horizon 2030 en
regardant finalement la démographie des
territoires et
départements il ne s'agit pas d'aller
chercher au-delà des 10 % d'une classe
d'âge ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui
alors c'est adapté en fonction des
territoires bien évidemment vous savez
que Mayotte et lag guuyane ont un fort
taux de natalité avec une croissance
démographique importante et donc nous
opérons des bascules d'efforts entre les
Antilles ou malheureusement deux
facteurs concourrentss vident les les
deux îles de la Martinique et de la
Guadeloupe de leur jeunesse la première
c'est bien entendu le sold de naturel
qui est négatif et puis ensuite un sold
de migratoire très important parce que
nombre de jeunes quittent le territoire
leur leurs îles pour aller faire leurs
études ou dans l'Hexagone voire au
Canada voilà donc le vivier dans lequel
nous allons puiser à hauteur de 10 %
dans ce créneau 1825 ans bah se faiblit
aux Antilles reste stable euh à la
Réunion est en forte augmentation euh à
Mayotte et euh en Guyane donc des
bascules d'efforts de cadre sont en
cours pour réduire un peu la voilure des
régiments des deux départements
américains pour basculer pour une partie
sur la Guyane pour une partie sur
Mayotte et puis quelques membres vers la
Polynésie française puisqueil faut créer
une compagnie supp suémentaire comme l'a
souhaité le président de la
République je le disais avec 1300 cadre
on a une organisation optimisée
et
je ne cesse de dire qu'il faut contenir
maintenant son développement à ce qui
existe non seulement parce que de
nouvelles formations administrative
coûte de l'argent à la République mais
également parce que je pour aller faire
autre chose ailleurs il faudra que je
prenne de la substance dans les
formations administratives existantes
pour aller créer d'autres formations
administratives parce que bien entendu
aujourd'hui mon format est à 1300 cadres
et en dehors d'une décision qui ne qui
n'est pas de mon niveau et bien les
effectifs des cadres n'augmenteront
pas
alors on a dans le plan ambition horizon
2030 un objectif qui est de former
éventuellement les jeunes chefs d'équipe
ça ça passe bien entendu par un stage
qui ne
peut-être un stage long au sein de notre
formation parce que bien évidemment
lorsque vous
travaillez dans une entreprise et que le
chef d'entreprise souhaiterait vous
donner des qualifications
supplémentaires ce stage de chef
d'équipe il doit se faire sur la base un
stage auprès du SMA parce que vous
n'allez pas perdre votre rémunération
pour venir au SMA le temps de la
formation et revenir à l'entreprise il y
a une perte de financière trop
importante et donc on propose et on va
proposer dès cette année des stages
justement de chefs d'équipe aux
entrepris pour
permettre d'améliorer à la fois les
compétences du de leadership et de
manager de ces jeunes futurs chefs
d'équipe et également renforcer euh les
entreprises qui sont désireuses de de
voir leurs jeunes
progresser alors il m'a été demandé de
parler aussi des métiers de la
sécurité dans les chacune des SEP
formations administratives nous avons
une filière qui dure 1 an d'agents de
prévention et de
sécurité alors
ou une Corte d'une vingtaine par an voir
dans les grosses formations
administratives comme à la Réunion et en
en Guyane une quarantaine voilà donc
c'est une formation qui est longue parce
qu'elle est maillée d'un certain nombre
d'examens contrôlés par les préfectures
ou les Haut- commommissariats et qui
délivr un titre professionnel sans
lequel vous ne pouvez pas exercer il
vous faut une carte professionnelle pour
pouvoir exercer le métier d'agent de
prévention de sécurité et
donc bien entendu nos jeunes suivent
cette formation obtiennent le titre 3 et
on a à peu près en moyenne 50 jeunes par
an sachant queon a les formations se
chevauchent euh voilà donc de 50 à
80 il nous avait été demandé de regarder
si on était en capacité
dans déployer pour les Jeux Olympiques
bon au maximum on pouvait en déployer
qu'une trentaine parce que il faut être
titulaire de la carte professionnelle
pour pouvoir
exercer on a d'autres filières bien
entendu au profit d'administration qui
sont les prépar donc on a une filière
qui s'appelle la pmspa préparation au
métier du service public et de
l'administration donc qui facilite
l'accès au concours de la fonction
publique du service public et pas
uniquement dans le domaine de la
sécurité on a un partenariat étroit par
exemple à Mayotte avec la gendarmerie
qui pour avoir des gendarmes adjoint
volontairees ou des sous-officiers de
gendarmerie nous a demandé une filière
particulière on assure la formation
militaire initiale et ensuite c'est une
formation qui est réalisé par les
gendarmes sur la base des cours
nécessaires à connaître pour pouvoir
passer le concours de gendarmerie et de
sousoffici on va on vient d'en ouvrir
une également
guyan à titre d'exemple les texes
législatif réglementair qu'il
conviendrait
d'adapter
bon pour mieux répondre aux enjeux
d'insertion parce que c'est ça
l'objectif et puis pour changer les
systèmes d'information nous on a un
verrou qui est la rgpd et tant que la
rgpd est en place on peut difficilement
échanger avec d'autres organismes raison
pour laquelle d'ailleurs je ne peux pas
renseigner au-delà des 6 mois le taux
d'insertion puisque je n'est pas
autorisé je ne suis pas autorisé à
manipuler les chiffres et donc comme ce
sont des croisements de données
entre Pôle emploi et le numéro Inc mais
moi je ne suis pas autorisé à le faire
donc ce sont des organismes spécialisés
qui doivent pouvoir le faire
voà bon après vous avez bien entendu
pour un certain nombre de territoires au
regarde du
décrochage des
rémunérations par rapport au coût de la
vie et bien un effort potentiel à
faire mais qui ne touche pas que les
militaires he bien entendu
euh donc qui est en cours de d'étude au
moins au ministère des armées qui
s'appelle l'indemnité de résidence dans
les
outrmers qui vient essayer de de faire
un peu ce que fait l'indemnité de
résidence à l'étranger que vous
connaissez et qui vient moduler en
fonction des facteurs économiques des
territoires ben une un montant financier
adapté au coût de la vie
localement voilà et puis pour nos jeunes
parce que il faut aussi penser à nos
jeunes vous avez une j'ai une difficulté
particulière qui est liée à cette
indexation dans les territoires c'est
que les jeunes du services militair
adaptés qui sont volontaires techniciens
ont une sole qui est indexée sur celle
du territoire et je ne suis pas
compétitif pour proposer un premier
emploi en milieu militaire
comparativement à d'autres lorsque il
est titulaire d'un titre professionnel
de peintre en bâtiment et que je cherche
un formateur je vais le payer en
Guadeloupe 1100 € pendant que à l'exter
illeurs on va lui proposer 2000 2100 €
même si derrière ces 1100 € il y a
d'autres facteurs à prendre en compte
bien évidemment que sont en particulier
le logement et l'alimentation mais comme
tout jeune à la fin du mois je regarde
ce qui tombe sur mon compte et je
préfère avoir 2002 que
1100 même si je fais pas je fais
abstraction du logement et de
l'alimentation qui est compris dans le
contrat voilà j'enai terminé j'ai essayé
de répondre à à vos questions merci euh
général pour votre exposé vraiment très
très précis je vais laisser la parole à
nos rapporteur donc Philippe Bas puis
Victorin
Lurel mon Général j'ajoute mes
remerciements à ce de notre présidente
votre exposé a été tellement complet que
les questions que j'avais mis en
réserves ont été largement
anticipé j'ai quand même envie de vous
demander quel pourrait être les
perspectives d'extension du service que
vous assumer tout en ayant parfaitement
compris ce que vous nous avez dit de la
manière la plus claire c'est-à-dire que
il n'est pas réaliste
d'imaginer augmenter le potentiel de %
d'une classe
d'âge et c'est déjà un très beau
résultat je trouve parce que ça n'est
pas
anecdotique dans
cette dans cette population mais est-ce
que des évolution vous paraîtrait
souhaitable si vous en aviez les les
moyens par exemple vous soullignez que
sur le
plan de l'information
statistique vous ne pouvez pas avoir
beaucoup d'information au-delà du
premier semestre suivant la fin de la
formation euh c'est pas l'aspect
statistique
qui retient mon attention c'est l'idée
que peut-être ces jeunes même si ils ont
un taux d'insertion professionnelle très
élevé pour être accompagné dans des
missions d'intérêt général qu'une partie
d'entre eux peuvent avoir vous vous en
faites en quelque sorte des agents de
dévelppement économique et social dans
la société ultramarine est-ce qu'audelà
de la formation peut
concevoir l'idée d'un
accompagnement
dans leur action d'agent de
développement économique et social si on
peut les qualifier de cette de cette
manière vous avez évoqué par
ailleurs la formation à des missions de
sécurité on a naturellement tendance à
on sa que un encadrement militaire
conduit assez naturellement vers ce type
d'orientation euh mais de fait ça n'est
le cas que marginalement puisque vous
avez cité euh
50 à 80 jeunes euh dans ces formation
est-ce que c'est pour vous une priorité
euh de de développer
cette orientation ou au contraire vous
préférez euh pour maintenir euh un flux
de volontaire
euh suffisamment ouvert sur d'autres
centres d'intérêt éviter que on finisse
par assimiler le
service militaire adapté
à une organisation de recrutement pour
former à des missions de sécurité donc
en vous posant la question je formule
déjà l'amorce d'une d'une réponse mais
j'aimerais le la valider la valider euh
avec vous euh plus généralement au fond
le bilan est bon vous l'avez rappelé
euh euh nos sociétés ultramarines euh
adhèrent fortement euh à ce à ce
dispositif vous l'avez rappelé aussi
mais précisément parce que ça réussit
bien j'ai envie de vous demander de quoi
rêveriez-vous pour l'avenir du service
militaire adapté pour franchir de
nouvelles étapes
monsieur le sénateur si je peux me
permettre alors pour répondre à votre
première question bon bien évidemment
euh les chefs de section qui sont ceux
qui encadrent les jeunes et qui ont
charge d'âme font tous les efforts
nécessaires pour
aller s'occuper des jeunes bien au-delà
de de leur passage en régiment bon alors
on est confronté
à un petit problème c'est que les jeunes
souvent changent de téléphone
ne regarde pas forcément leur
adresse internet mail pardon et donc de
ce fait on perd un peu le
contact bon pour aller un peu plus loin
nous avons un certain nombre de jeunes
qui s'inscrivent directement dans une
activité particulière et qui sont
référencés sont les jeunes qui suivent
justement dans les territoires où où
les risques naturels sont importants
suivent un module particulier qui qui
est dispensé par la sécurité civile qui
est le
le équipier sauvetage d'blément c'est
donc quelque chose qui est plutôt lié
aux périodes cyclonique ou aux
zones voilà va me revenir
pour donc en fait on les zones sismiques
merci voilà donc ces jeunes sont formés
contrôlés inscrits auprès de la
préfecture parce que ils ont une
validité de diplôme de 3 mois de 3 ans
pardon donc ces gens-là continuent à
contribuer et peuvent intervenir ça a
d'ailleurs été le cas en janvier dernier
en Guadeloupe où un certain nombre de
jeunes qui étaient plutôt de la région
de Baster sont allés spontanément aider
et sont allés rejoindre les les quelques
personnels du SMA qui ont été déployés
pour aider la population suite à la
tempête
tropicale on a
créé le 6 juillet 2023 sous l'égide de
la Fondation agir contre l'exclusion la
fondation du Service Militaire Adapté
elle a pour objet
aussi d'aller accompagner des
jeunes pour lesquels il reste encore
quelques Levi en
insertion l'objectif étant de les aider
soit financièrement soit par du tutor et
du mécén de compétence à les emmener au
plus loin dans leur projet
professionnel typiquement un jeune
lorsqu'il sort du SMA va avoir une
difficulté à se loger pourquoi parce que
si il n'est pas chez ses parents et
qu'il n'a pas de véhicule qu'il a besoin
d'être à proximité de son lieu de
travail et bien il ne pourra pas
souscrire à un logement parce que les
revenus qu'il a eu pendant l'année ne
sont pas suffisants parce qu'il n'a pas
non plus de bulletin de salaire et donc
lorsqu'il faudra monter le
dossier il ne pourra pas prétendre à un
logement puisqu'il sera pas capable de
payer une caution il sera pas forcément
il aura pas les trois bulletins de
salaire nécessaires donc cette fondation
elle a pour objet par exemple d'aider
par le biais de bailleurs sociaux avec
lesquels la Fondation est en partenariat
proposer la gratuité de la caution et
des trois des trois premiers mois pour
le jeûne charge à la fondation de
remplacer le jeûne et donc pendant les 3
mois où il est à l'emploi obtenir les
documents nécessaires pour aller plus
loin et donc pouvoir continuer à louer
le logement qui lui a été trouvé c'est
également l'accompagnement dans la
création d'entreprise aujourd'hui créer
une entreprise c'est pas si simple en
dehors des statut juridique il faut
aussi s'assurer potentiellement d'un
business plan pour se voir prêter de
l'argent il faut ensuite l'issue d'un
premier
exercice rendre des comptes
financièrement donc la fondation
aujourd'hui a dans ses partenaires qui
font du mesena de compéten des banquiers
qui peuvent aider à faire un business
plan des juristes en capacité d'aider à
la rédaction des statuts mais bien
entendu aussi des experts comptables
pour permettre aux jeunes au bout d'une
année de rendre des comptes pour pouvoir
payer ses impôts sur la société donc on
essaie d'aller plus loin et ça rebondit
un peu sur votre deuxième question
qu'est-ce que je on l'a pas
arrivé chef de cor 2009 moi je m'étais
inquiété de savoir ce qu'allait faire
les à l'époque 18 % de jeunes
guadeloupéen qui passaient par le
régiment et qui n'allait pas à l'emploi
donc qu je me suis posé la question de
savoir quelles étaient quel aurait pu
être une action complémentaire pour leur
permettre d'aller à l'emploi bon en
prenant le SMA j'ai demandé à ce qu'on
regarde plusieurs choses les maisons du
SMA dans l'Hexagone pour que un certain
nombre de jeunes qui viennent suivre des
formation complémentaire dans l'Hexagone
mais et un point auprès duquel il soit
il puisse se rattacher pour un certain
nombre de démarches
administrative et puis la fondation en
disant bon ben voilà comment je peux
aider un jeune à
s'installer donc ça a été un travail
long hein de de d'un peu plus de 2 ans
donc a qui a abouti au choix d'être une
fondation abritée pour 1000 raisons je
n'ai pas le support juridique je n'ai
pas les équipes enfin la Fondation
pardon n'a pas les équipes pour pouvoir
assurer toutes les fonctions d'une
fondation et puis il aurait fallu que
attendre 5 ans pour pouvoir bénéficier
du statut de fondation reconnu d'utilité
publique pour les réscrits fiscaux pour
les donateurs donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle on a choisi plutôt d'être
abrité pour commencer voilà l'objectif
c'est
210 jeunes accompagnés par
an 210 jeunes sur les 4800 ça va faire à
peu près 4 % en plus et donc notre
objectif c'est d'essayer d'être encore
plus
performant parce que l'argent public qui
nous est donné au titre de la LFI pour
constituer le budget du SMA
euh ne peut pas tout faire et l'argent
privé qui nous est donné enfin qui est
donné la Fondation ainsi que les méin de
compéten va permettre justement d'aller
encore plus loin pour accompagner ces
jeunes pour les métiers de la sécurité
que vous évoquez
il y a des restrictions à la mise en
formation la première des restrictions
c'est que le jeune lorsqu'il se présente
il
doit avoir un casier judiciaire
vierge nombre de jeunes ont pu être sous
main de justice avant leur majorité il y
a effacement à la majorité mais
certaines affaires lourdes restent
inscrites et puis après c'est comme
c'est un document nécessaire pour
l'obtention de la carte professionnelle
bien évidemment moi je ne peux pas faire
[Musique]
tout j'accepte des jeunes avec des
casiers légers mais je ne peux pas
sursoir au casier vierge pour l'agent de
prévention et de sécurité donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle aussi on a des
Cortes de 12
à 12 en gén
de corps par an 24 par régiment
multiplié par 7 vous avez 80 jeunes qui
passent mais je je pourrais enfin dans
les gros régiment j'ai plus de de jeunes
en formation d'agents de prévention et
de sécurité parce que le bassin et le
vivier dans lequel je je je puise est
supérieur mais là aussi il faut je ne
fais pas de la formation uniquement pour
de la formation je fais bien de la
formation pour aller insérer le jeune
dans la vie économique
et les sociétés de gardienage privé qui
emploient ces agents de prévention et de
sécurité et ben elles ont un volume de
personnel dans leur structure qui reste
fixe ou qui progressent légèrement et
qui ne progresseraiit sans doute pas à
la vitesse à laquelle on pourrait former
des agents de prévention de
sécurité raison pour laquelle on reste
sur un volume modeste voilà et ce sont
des sociétés vous le savez où le
turnover des des agents est très
important en général un agent fait deux
à trois sociétés et au bout de 3 ans
change d'orientation parce que la
rémunération n'est pas là et parce que
le métier reste
difficile merci Victor
alurel merci madame la Présidente euh
monsieur mon général je suis très
content de vous avoir puisque j'avoue
avoir eu une sorte de propension euh à
l'époque
pour ce service-là
et je suis resté un petit peu attentif à
son
évolution alors j'ai quelques questions
à vous poser autant c'est bien vu et
depuis longtemps euh le RSMA autant
depuis quelques dizaines d'années et on
entend une critique notamment par euh
certains militants politiques certains
partis politiques pour dire on ne peut
pas concevoir la formation et
l'insertion des jeunes sous l'angle
militaire la militarisation de
l'encadrement de la jeunesse ça a été
dit dans une campagne électorale c'était
Solen royal et j'entends récemment le
notre premier ministre dire on va
peut-être aller là c'est une demande
sociale de dire que il y a quelques
vertus à à faire du de la formation
civique et citoyenne et le RSMA et et
bien placé pour le faire mais j'ai
entendu chez moi en Guadeloupe des
syndicats et des partis politiques
notamment nationalistes dire que ce
n'est plus concevable et qu'il faut à
côté du RSMA un autre arsenal de moyens
pour les formations d'une autre nature
donc c'est politique et philosophique
mais je vous soumets cette affaire là
que c'est arrivé à votre niveau sur la
nature l'identité de ce type de
formation ils sont utilité sa pertinence
et son efficacité deuxème question c'est
sur
l'efficacité moi ministre à
l'époque on se réjouissait tous c'est
toujours le cas sur le taux d'insertion
de dire que à l'époque c'était 75 80 %
des jeunes formés
au RSMA s'incérit il y a eu une
polémique je sais pas si c'est arrivé à
votre niveau sur la qualité de
l'indicateur est-ce qu'il était diable
est-ce que c'est vraiment ça est-ce
qu'il y a des chroniques publiées pour
savoir un peu le cheminement de celles
et de ceux qui ont été formés au RSMA et
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont devenus après donc
peut-être que ça peut monter en
puissance et vérifier ça 3è question
aujourd'hui quel est le déploiement
logistique du RSMA dans les territoires
à l'époque il y avait une controverse
entre la Guadeloupe et Saint-Martin ENF
rés av un quota pour les jeunes
Saint-Martinois
ou construire un centre à SaintMartin il
me semble que la décision qui a été
prise c'est de dire une centaine de
places ou 75 places réservé pour les
jeunes de Saint-Martin à guel deuxième
chose il y avait la même controverse sur
walis et Futuna à l'époque fallait-il
construire un centre un régiment ou une
brigade vous me direz quelle est la
distinction en terme de corps euh où
eston aujourd'hui et à Mayot il y a eu
pendant longtemps des interrogations je
crois que c'est réglé aujourd'hui il y a
donc un régiment à à à maot bon donc
j'aimerais savoir aujourd'hui quels sont
vos besoins dans ce domaine là ensuite
quel est le montant de votre budget
aujourd'hui moi en 2012 c'était déjà
l'objectif RSM à 6000 et ça a pris
beaucoup de temps et compen que c'est du
volontariat c'est pas si simple que ça
pour obtenir IR ces chiffres là donc on
est encore sur cette trajectoire là et
c'est vrai que c'est tangentiel mais je
apprends que vous êtes à 5800 6000 on
est proche de ça est-ce que d'autres
objectifs vous ont été assignés 78 10000
ça me paraît
compliqué pour pour il est un peu déjà
répondu j'aimerais savoir quelle est la
journée type d'un jeune stagiaire chez
vous euh le matin réveille tô on fait le
lit on salue le drapeau On dit bonjour
au chef est-ce que c'est bien ça euh non
mais vraiment parce que la question a
été posée ensuite est-ce que la question
qui a été posée que j'avais moimême
portter j'ai pas eu g cause d'autres
élus d'autres territoires l' pris on
avait demandé à côté du RSMA peut-être
pour parfaire son périmètre de formation
d'avoir des épides euh des établissement
public d'insertion et on disait de
défense euh euh nationale mais cétait
pour l'emploi mais il y avait une
possibilité d'avoir un épide puisque
c'est interministériel avec le ministère
du Travail il aussi le ministère de la
Défense ça a toujours été
refusé c'était dans l'obtique de
l'encadrement militaire ou une dose de
militarité comme vous dit euh ça n'a
jamais été euh euh adopté est-ce qu'il y
a a une raison particulière pour que
dans les autres ma il y ait pas l'Épide
euh bon pourquoi pas enfin
euh est-ce que vous avez des liens avec
les sessions régionales de l'ihodn
est-ce que au-delà de la question posé
sur la sécurité les mythil mais est-ce
que au-delà de donner une formation mais
le savoir être le savoir devenenir
est-ce que il y a des relations avec
session régional de l'ihn est-ce que
dernière question ça vous paraît
approprié pertinent pour l'Hexagone le
président m'avait interrogé à l'époque
en disant mais ton histoire de RSMA ça
nous paraît bien est-ce que on on
pourrait généraliser ça en guise de
réponse il y a eu comment on appelle ça
le SNU le service civique là c'est
ça ouis voilà
voilà quel donc quel avenir pour le RSMA
est-ce que ça restera
euh je sais pas pégoraatif enfermer dans
les autroms ou est-ce que ça peut
essmer en
hexagone monsieur le sénateur
euh le petit frère du Service Militaire
Adapté existe dans l'Hexagone ça
s'appelle le service militaire
volontaire sa structure est un peu
différente le volume de jeunes
accueillis et moindre mais parce que
vous avez aussi sur le territoire bien
plus de centres de
formation que ce soit de l'AFPA ou des
lycées professionnels qui peuvent
dispenser des formations
professionnelles au profit des jeunes
raison pour laquelle l'objectif du
général Brûlon qui commande le service
militaire adapté est de 1500
jeunes d'ailleurs un un centre a été
ouvert à Marseille il y a 2 jours
peut-être pas forcément à grand bruit
mais le le le secrétaire général pour
l'administration est allé sur place avec
le général
commandant directeur de du service
national et de la jeunesse pour
inaugurer ce nouveau centre qui avait
été vu par le Président de la République
à l'occasion d'un de ses déplacement à
Marseille donc je dirais que le
prolongement du SMA dans l'Hexagone est
le service militaire
volontaire vous
disiez 6 7 8 10000 jeunes je je reviens
au propos que j'ai tenu tout à l'heure
c'est que nous prenons ENF nous essayons
d'atteindre 10 % de la classe d'âge pour
pouvoir armer nos
régiments j'ai demandé à mon état-major
de regarder et c'est assez facile parce
que les ceux qui qui seront en 2030
potentiellement dans le vivier sont déjà
nés et
donc sur les
2500 à 700000 habitants que compte nos
territoires et
départements la classe d'âge des 18 à 25
ans à l'horizon 2030 est à environ
400000 lorsque je divise par le nombre
par le créneau des 7 et que je ramène à
10 % je serai à 4500 jeunes à 10 % bien
comme je vous l'ai dit on peut faire
effort pour aller au-delà mais euh de
toute manière il y a une contrainte qui
restera c'est celle du taux
d'encadrement de 20 %. c'est pour ça que
euh dans le cadre du Plan SMA 2025 que
j'ai regroupé hein parce que bien
entendu vous aviez SMA 2025 mon su
prédécesseur 2025 plus à la demande de
du ministre Lecornu ministre des
outresères de l'époque donc augmenté de
façon significative
euh il a il a souhaité 10 % bon Bercy
nous a dit avant que je ne vous donne de
l'argent atteignez les 6000 de nouveau
soyez en croisière à 6000 et on verra
pour augmenter les effectifs bon moi
financièrement aujourd'hui puisque c'est
une question que vous avez posé le
budget du service militaire adapté
d'environ 300 millions
d'euros dont une grosse partie
correspond au traitement et salaire à la
fois des volontaires et des cadres à peu
près les 2 tiers le relica étant divisé
en deux partie une partie fonctionnement
courant de l'ordre de 55 à 58 millions
d'euros et puis une partie
investissement du complément pour aller
à 100
millions le fonctionnement c'est bien
entendu toute la partie alimentation
soutien entretien des matériels et de de
l'immob obilier et puis l'investissement
c'est les acquisitions nécessaires au
plateau pédagogique pour la formation
professionnelle au fonctionnement
courant c'est les véhicules par exemple
double commande pour permettre à la
majorité des jeunes qui viennent au
service militaire adapté de passer le
permis de conduire parce que bien
entendu plus vous avez de voiture plus
vous avez de chance de leur donner du
temps de conduite com
parfistion oui j'y allais j'y arrivais
oui oui oui bien sûr bien sûr non mais
j'ai donc en fait exactement 67 % de mon
budget c'est la
LFI euh 32 % c'est le FSE et donc
l'Europe et le relolica étant pour une
faible part les taxes d'apprentissage et
pour
1,2 1,5 % les collectivité territoriale
l'appui localement des régions et des
territoires au profit du du Service
Militaire Adapté
voilà merci je vais laisser la parole à
mes collègues alors je vous propose euh
trois inter trois
questions avec et puis nous répondrons
le général répondra après trois
interventions donc je commence par
Vivette Lopez puis anque Pétrus et Marie
Laur
fin merci madame la Présidente générale
merci pour votre exposé très très
intéressant moi je vousoudrais évoquer
le recrutement alors certes je sais que
vous êtes militaire mais vous ne faites
pas cette formation pour le recrutement
militaire néanmoins est-ce que le bout
de ces 6 mois ou 12 mois de formation
cela a-t-il pu éveiller des vocations
est-ce que certains jeunes ont envie
d'intégrer donc le l'armée de terre de
l'air ou de la mer peu importe ou au
contraire il y a-t-il des jeunes qui au
bout de quelques jours ou voire au bout
d'un mois ne veulent plus rester et
souhaitent partir de chez vous est-ce
que l'armée se est intéressée par ces
jeunes parce que à l'époque où il
faisait 24 mois il y en avait peut-être
qui après s'engageer définitivement
est-ce que ça peut être le cas est-ce
que l'armée est intéressée par par ces
jeuneslà et deuxième petite question
est-ce que vous avez des diff pour
retrouver des entreprises qui recrutent
ces jeunesl je vous remercie
général Annique
Pétrus merci madame la Présidente merci
mon général pour votre exposé fort riche
le RSMA ne se présente plus euh nous
savons
tous les j'ai envie de dire les
bienfaits de du RSMA sur les différents
territoires où ils sont implantés
notamment en Martinique guadeloup Guyane
réunion Mayot Nouvelle-Calédonie et en
Polynésie française ainsi qu'à Périgueux
avec un centre dédié à la mobilité et à
la formation le RSMA est en capacité
d'accueillir chaque année plus de 6000
bénéficiaires ce dispositif apparaît
comme particulièrement performant
puisque le taux d'insertion stagiaire en
emploi ou ou en poursuite de formation
des volontaires stagiaires atteint des
niveaux très satisfaisants entre 74 et
77 % eu égard aux caractéristiques
socio-économiques des outremèes et des
jeunes
sélectionnés de plus ces résultats
montrent en outre une tendance à
l'augmentation en la qualité de
l'insertion révélée dans la
quasi-ttalité des territoires par la
part croissante des emplois durables
ainsi la part des volontairees stagiaire
bénéficiant d'un emploi durable CDI ou
CDD dans les 6 mois suivant la fin de
leur formation au SMA dépasse les 50
%. alors à Saint-Martin nous avons
quelques 4000 jeunes de moins de 25 ans
déscolarisés qui ne sont ni dans le
monde du travail ni dans celui de la
formation professionnelle ce douloureux
constat met à mal la cohérence sociale
de mon territoire leur ma représente une
solution pour ces jeunes en leur
proposant des formations
professionnelles parmi un panel de 28
filières de métiers mais aussi en leur
redonnant un cadre structuré et des
valeurs
euh cependant le coût de formation
l'éloignement l'absence des familles en
Guadeloupe sont des fraiss au départ de
ces jeunes Saint-Martinois qui ont aussi
cette incapacité de se loger vous en
avez fait allusion tout à l'heure
récemment l'implantation d'un RSMA à
Saint-Martin a été de nouveau remise sur
la table avec la mise en place d'une
compagnie de formation professionnelle
ou annexe du RSMA à Saint-Martin cette
compagnie pourrait proposer ainsi trois
ou quatre filières de formation en
relation avec les besoins territoriaux à
savoir BTP tourisme économie bleue
ouverte j'aimerais vous entendre sur ce
sujet nous tient particulièrement à cœur
à Saint-Martin j'aimerais aussi vous
dire et le le rapporteur monsieur Lurel
en faisait allusion tout à l'heure
euh nous avons une convention depuis
2014 avec le RSMA c'est l'objectif 100
euh qui permet et qui est renouvelé avec
la collectivité chaque année et je m'en
réjouis je vous remercie merci et puis
je vais céder la parole à Marie Laur
fineraor merci présidente mon général
j'ai beaucoup apprécié votre votre
intervention et je dois vous avouer que
j'ai beaucoup de respect et d'admiration
pour le travail réalisé par le RSMA en
Guyane aussi sachez d'ailleurs que je
milite pour le retour du service
militaire en outremè en tous les cas
chez moi en guyan mais en attendant
j'aimerais savoir si vous envisagez
d'ouvrir un RSMA au RSMA de guyan des
sections susceptibles d'accueillir les
jeunes filles mères comme cela existe
ailleurs voilà
merci je vais essayer de répondre dans
l'ordre donc oui effectivement euh
l'objectif prioritaire de la formation
professionnelle dans les régiments du
Service Militaire Adapté n'est pas
l'intégration dans les forces armées et
effectivement nombre de jeunes qui
découvrant l'environnement dans lequel
ils évoluent au quotidien
imagine faire carrière puisque nous
avons l'opportunité de leur proposer des
carrières dynamiques pour de milita dur
sousofficiers voire d'officiers pour les
les plus brillants et donc bien
naturellement un certain nombre de
jeunes pendant leur formation
professionnelle se renseignent pour
pouvoir rejoindre les armées l'année
dernière 584 jeunes c'estàd à peu près
10 % on rejoint les armées
d'abord parce que les armées ont des
sont ont besoin aussi de jeunes
qualifiés dans des métiers
particulier et parce que ils sont
attirés bien naturellement eux vers le
métier des armes c'est
assez différent en fonction des
territoires on a souvent tendance à dire
que les territoires du Pacifique
attirent beaucoup je dirais que l'année
dernière il a un petit peu moins attiré
que les années précédentes et euh c'est
si je peux me permettre monsieur le
sénateur la Guadeloupe qui tire le
pompon puisque 114 jeunes qui ont du SMA
de la Guadeloupe ont rejoint les forces
armées alors ils rejoignent les forces
armées les directions et services avec
un avantage je dirais pour la Marine
nationale et l'armée de l'air qui ont
encore des implantations localement avec
des formations administratives en
capacité d'accueillir des jeunes pour
qui rest sur leur territoire l'armée de
terre a
pour a beau avoir des formations
administratives dans les territoires de
ils viennent d'abord dans l'Hexagone et
prétendent à retourner ensuite dans leur
territoire lorsque ils le peuvent donc à
peu près 10 %
voilà pour ce qui est de pour ce qui est
de Saint-Martin effectivement depuis
2012 la convention SMA 100 existe elle a
été mise en œuvre avec d'excellents
résultats sur les trois premières années
et
puis ça a été un petit peu plus
compliqué alors je en enlevant l'année
covid qui qui a quand même vu les
effectifs du SMA baisser fortement sur 6
années cumulé 330 jeunes ont rejoint la
Guadeloupe
pour suivre une desformation
administrative et une centaine seulement
vous allez me dire une centaine sont
retournés dans leur territoire et 60 15
sont allés à l'emploi la difficulté
aujourd'hui d'implantation du SMA c'est
que on ne sait pas ou plus exactement le
le préfet
aujourd'hui ne sait pas où il pourrait
installer un SMA donc dans les échanges
qu'il y a actuellement entre le
ministère des outresmers et la
collectivité il a été demandé de trouver
un endroit où potentiellement il y avait
du foncier pour installer qu'elles
étaient effectivement les formations
professionnelles à dispenser et queles
seraient les débouchés potentiellement
localement parce qu'on parlait tout à
l'heure de tissu économique et de
société en
capacité là encore l'objectif c'est bien
de faire de la formation professionnelle
pour insérer vous parliez du BTP sur les
6 ans 17 jeunes avaient pris enfin 17
jeunes sont
retournés sur les 75 les 17 17 jeunes
seulement sont allés dans le BTP à
Saint-Martin alors j'entends bien qu'il
faille développer mais il faut aussi
qu'il ait des entreprises derrière en
capacité d'accueillir ces jeunes voilà
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui euh la porte n'est pas
fermée mais
que on attend de la collectivité et du
préfet en place les éléments de réponse
qui lui ont été posés à l'occasion de
d'un
échange au cours du mois de novembre
voilà pour ce qui est
des de la Guyane bon le vous le savez
votre territoire est
dynamique il va y avoir une bascule
d'effort certainement entre Cayenne et
le Grand Ouest guyanaet au regard de
l'accélération de la population ce qui
fait que finalement le choix qui a été
fait en 2009 d'implanter le SMA
définitivement à Saint-Jean était plutôt
une bonne idée tout en conservant un
pôle
akayenne ce régiment fera
l'objet d'une montée en puissance qui
sera liée bien entendu à la capacité que
nous avons à construire pour accueillir
l'objectif au ici étant de permettre aux
jeunes d'être dans de bonnes conditions
d'accueil pour suivre leur formation ça
commence par la formation militaire
iniicial mais également dans les unités
élémentaires dans le plan horizon 2030
il y a un item pour les jeunes mères
célibataires parce qu'on sait que ça
représente une population importante une
population qui est souvent parce qu'elle
a été maèire très jeune
peu diplômé et donc nous avons nous
cherchons les meilleurs moyens pour
accueillir ces jeunes mère célibataire
et de faire en sorte qu'ell soi là aussi
avec leurs enfants
donc aujourd'hui vous avez un premier
projet majeur qui est en cours de
construction encore en gouallelou vous
allez me dire d'une crèche avec un
certain nombre de lits partagés entre le
régiment et la commune de bmao et qui
permet d'accueillir ces jeunes filles de
les loger sur
place de pouvoir les déposer le matin
aller suivre leur formation et récupérer
l'enfant dans une structure un peu
particulière puisque les horaires ne
sont pas celles d'une crèche habituelle
mais adapté au rythme de vie de la jeune
femme ça c'est un premier exemple le
deuxième exemple c'est la réunion qui a
travaillé
sur une crèche à vocation
intergénérationnel à savoir que les
jeunes filles sont logées dans un
bâtiment où il y a des gens d'âge plus
avancé en capacité parce qu'ils sont
référents si on dépasse ses horaires
d'aller chercher l'enfant s'en occuper
ch à la jeune fille qui est logée et qui
suit sa formation ensuite de participer
à la vie de la collectivité et en
particulier d'appuyer le weekend en
allant faire des courses en jouant au
domino parfois avec la personne qui est
référente pour
l'enfant donc en guyan bien entendu ça
fera l'objet d'une démarche particulière
si vous voulez nous avons commencé ce
plan 2025 et 2025 plus que j'ai appelé
horizon 2030 parce que parce que pour
mettre mon grain de sel j'allais faire
20 25 plus plus donc ça pas de grand
intérêt donc j'ai donné j'ai essayé de
donner un peu de lisibilité et donc bien
entendu on conduit une expérimentation
lorsqu'elle est validée on
généralise c'est la raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui l'ensemble des régiments du
Service Militaire Adapté peuvent
proposer le permis pour tous c'està-dire
tous les jeunes qui sont non titulaires
du permis de conduire mais qui sont dans
les règles parce que je lutte aussi
contre les addictions bien entendu et
donc je ne le jeune qui est contrôlé
positif à l'occasion de son séjour
régiment ou est préalablement au permis
de construire de conduire pardon bien
évidemment je ne vais pas le présenter
au permis de conduire je donne bien un
permis de conduire pas un permis de tuer
et donc j'essaie d'éduquer donc le jeune
s'il peut décrocher de ses addiction
c'est une bonne chose et donc il va au
permis sur la population j'ai à peu près
88 % des jeunes qui
sont envoyés au permis de
conduire j'ai 81 % de réussite au permis
de conduire c'està-dire que malgré le
fort tau d'ilétrisme de nos
jeunes
l'implication du jeune bien entendu mais
également des formateurs permettent à
ces jeunes d'obtenir le sésame qui leur
permet d'aller à l'emploi vous le savez
bien et donc la général
nous avons commencé par Mayotte avec la
mise en place de moyens novateurs dont
les simulateurs de
conduite on a vu parce que Mayotte a
plus de 60 % de jeunes qui arrivent au
régiment qui sont illétrés au regard des
critères de la
nlci je duplique parce que ça fonctionne
dans les autres formations
administratives et ce qui nous a permis
de gagner quasiment 5 points cette année
de
permis
euh tan Mohamed
soali sans transition c'est
ça
merci madame la Présidente euh mon
général à mon tour je tiens à
saluer le la la qualité j'allais dire du
travail la qualité du SMA tout court
euh c'est important euh de dire quand
les choses marchent dans nos territoires
où malheureusement
euh ce n'est pas toujours le cas
[Musique]
euh je reviens à la
charge j'ai bien nous avons bien entendu
vos développement sur ces sorte de se
critique que vous avez atteint ou que
vous êtes en passe d'atteindre et que
vous le le le SMA ne saurait en faire
plus
euh mais dans SMA il a adapté
euh et c'est l'une de vos marques de
fabrique c'est l'une des raisons qui
font que ça fonctionne aussi bien en
notre m et moi en tant qu'élu je ne peux
pas me résoudre à constater dans le même
territoire à la fois l'excellence et
puis le le pire qu'est-ce qui pourrait
au milieu être fait pour sans entrer
dans le cœur du dispositif le sans sans
intégrer les dispositifs que le SMA
puisse euh aider
concourir à à aider parce que il faut le
rappeler la formation c'est d'abord
l'apanage des collectivités euh et
peut-être des services de l'État ensuite
mais qu'est-ce qui pourrait être fait
est-ce que vous pensez que quelque chose
d'intermédiaire pourrait être fait euh
pour
euh aider à à encadrer euh aider à
structurer aider à donner une seconde
chance aux jeunes de de ces
territoires et notamment deux de ces
territoires ou trois la Guyane Mayotte
Saint-Martin euh où la jeunesse
augmente si je puis dire le taux de
jeunes ne cesse d'augmenter euh
contrairement à d'autres territoire
merci pour pour répondre all non
oui pour répondre à votre
question les territoires pour lesquels
la population est en
augmentation l'effort est fait par la
bascule que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
l'objectif étant de d'aller
chercher plus de jeunes donc typiquement
à terme le deuxème la deuxième plus
grosse formation administrative du
Service Militaire Adapté après la
réunion qui accueille à peu près 1400
jeunes parents ce sera
Mayotte très près derrière la Guyane
mais là d'abord il faut qu'on puisse
construire alors vous connaissez
Mayotte vous connaissez combannie vous
voyez bien le régiment vous voyez qu'il
est bien enfermé et donc aujourd'hui on
est à la recherche al les travaux
avancent he en lien avec laadfip le
préfet la collectivité comme
pour trouver un terrain sur lequel on
pourra créer une nouvelle unité et non
pas délocalisé mais un peu désengorgé
comagnie pour permettre d'accueillir
mieux et plus donc à terme on devrait
avoir quasi 1000 jeunes à Mayotte à peu
près la même chose en
Guyane on
a en lien avec les les les les
réactorats mais on ne peut pas non plus
a
multiplié les les les formations on a
développé ce parcours volontaire jeune
cadet qui présente enfin qui obtient
d'excellents résultats 90 % des jeunes
reprennent l'école et passent à l'étage
supérieur
euh pour des raisons juridiques j'ai
préféré transformer le statut de ces
jeunes vol ces volon jeunes cadet en
créant une préparation militaire du
service militaire adapté qui donne un
cadre juridique plus fort
pour la formation administrative qui
permet aussi aux jeunes d'avoir une
assurance particulière et d'être suivi
médicalement par les médecins militaires
ce qui n'était pas le cas avant et donc
on peut diversifier les activités et on
peut
et cette préparation militaire elle dure
un mois alors elle est perlée pour les
jeunes bien entendu de l'éducation
nationale puisqueils ont autre chose
aussi à faire que uniquement venir au
régiment pour être je dirais éduqué plus
que le reste mais ça peut faire partie
des propositions c'està-dire
proposer pendant les de mois d'été alors
c'est compliqué pour nous parce que vous
savez que c'est la période de charnière
de renouvellement des cadres mais il
peut être envisageable justement de
mettre cette préparation militaire du
SMA à profit pour accompagner d'autres
jeunes que ceux qui sont en décrochage
scolaire je ne suis pas le seul acteur
vous l'avez évoqué pour s'occuper de la
jeunesse le le seul avantage que j'ai
c'est le contrat parce que comme je le
disais tout à l'heure dans mon propos le
contrat contraint et c'est un peu la
force de la du statut de militaire
c'est-à-dire que je suis en capacité de
sanctionner et donc de de contraindre le
jeune à ne pas pouvoir rentrer le
weekend chez lui je mais je peux aussi
le
récompenser voilà ce que d'autres
dispositifs ne peuvent pas faire voilà
nous un jeune qui ne vient pas en
formation professionnelle c'est assez
simple on va le sanctionner et on va le
reprendre et le réinjecter dans la
formation professionnelle en disant bon
maintenant ça suffit si tu veux t'en
sortir c'est maintenant alors qu'un
jeune qui suit une formation
professionnelle en lycée professionnel à
partir du moment où il a plus de 16 ans
s'il veut pas venir il vient pas et il y
a pas de contrainte derrière cette
affaire là voilà c'est ce qui fait aussi
un peu la force du dispositif
alors il faut pas non plus en abuser
hein bien entendu il faut le faire en
étant bienveillant et c'est ce qu'on
essaie de faire c'est pour ça aussi que
ça fonctionne
oui mais est-ce qu'il y a des jeunes qui
décrochent complètement qui ne veulent
pas du tout au bout de de quelques
jours bien entendu parce que ces jeunesl
ne s'attendaiit pas forcément au type de
vie que l'on impose je dirais au moins
initialement
un petit peu plus dur que de se lever à
midi et de se coucher à minuit on décale
un peu la journée si vous voulez on se
lève plutôt à 5h et on se couche plutôt
à 21h voilà mais très
clairement beaucoup de jeunes d'ailleurs
sont assez reconnaissants en disant vous
avez réussi à me remettre dans un rythme
qui n'était pas du tout le bienen alors
bien entendu vous avez mais on a un taux
d'atrition qui est d'environ 10 %
c'est-à-dire 10 % des jeunes qui
viennent finement décide de partir parce
que ça leur convient pas vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure je reviens sur
votre question préliminaire première
pardon vous m'avez demandé si nos jeunes
ultramarins qui s'engageaient étaient
bons alors juste deux chiffres donc sur
les 600 jeunes qui viennent des
territoires on constate que le taux
d'attrition c'està-dire ceux qui
finalement ont fait la démarche de venir
et puis d'arrêter est de 4
% lorsque le jeune oui seulement parce
qu'il a déjà une première expérience
militaire et finalement il sait en
arrivant dans le régiment ou dans les
formations administratives ce qu'il ce
qu'on attend de lui alors que lorsque
vous êtes un hexagonal ou un ultramarin
n'étant pas passé par le Service
Militaire Adapté c'est plutôt 20 % des
jeunes qui finalement au bout d'un
certain temps quittent donc il y a un
bienfait à venir au SMA pour ces jeunes
là mais ils auraient peut-être été dans
les 20 % s'il n'y étaient pas passé
voilà
merci je vais laisser la parole à notre
collègue sa
omaroli dit bien sûr T et les
autres
juste micro ne peut pas madame vous
voulez vous me
censurez par rapport à ce que vous avez
dit mon général c'est pas vous de vous
occuper de la jeunesse c'est vrai mais
c'est à nous aussi les élus lorsqu'on
voit quelque chose qui ne va pas dans
nos collectivités de le
relever la population de Mayotte vous
avez dit tout à l'heure 60 % des jeunes
sont étrés euh ça c'est vrai et que de
plus en plus la population de Mayotte
aujourd'hui 50 % de la population est
étrangère moi j'étais professeur au
lycée j'avais des très bons élèves qui m
malheureusement ne pouvent pas rentrer
dans aucun dispositif de formation tout
simplement parce qu'ils avaient pas de
papier ils sont les plus nombreux et
c'est eux qui nous posent problème et
que vous avez dit en préambule queil
faut d'abord être français pour rentrer
dans le dispositif de formation de GSMA
euh moi je pose la question à nous les
élus ici euh qu'est-ce qu'on fait de ces
jeunes effectivement qui sont de plus en
plus nombreux
qu'on a menti en quelque sorte parce
qu'on leur a dit lorsque on les a mis à
l'école on dit que vous allez vous en
sortir bien sûr en suivant une formation
certains ont leur bac certains n'ont pas
eu leur bac certains ont je
dirais une carte de séjour sauf il y a
pas de dispositif pour
eux donc je pense que cette réflexion
doit être menée euh sérieusement parce
que quand on regarde aujourd'hui à
mayott la prison c'est 75 % de cette
population là jeune
étranger ils n'ont pas d'autres
alternatives et quand on peut pas les
garder en prison je dirais d'une manière
indéfinie ils sortent et quand ils
sortent et bien on voit ce qui se passe
dans dans nos villages donc moi je c'est
juste une réflexion pour ces jeunes ils
sont de plus en plus nombreux
malheureusement qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire pour pour clore cette série de
questions j'aimerais aussi souligner à
quel point je soutiens d'initiative du
RSMA du SMA je je milite pour
justement perdurer peut-être le
développer encore plus
et particulièrement certains jeunes vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure certains
jeunes qui avaient qui possédaient un
casier judiciaire vous avez évoqué aussi
la base du volontariat
euh je pensais aux relations qu'on
pourra avoir avec la justice les accords
avec la justice certains jeunes qui
commencent à dévier justement pour des
peines qui ont des peines mineures ne
pourrait-on pas
euh leur proposer de rejoindre une
deuxème chance de de rejoindre le le SMA
plutôt que de les orienter vers parfois
la prison ne serait-ce que pour de
petites peines mais dont on connaît
l'effet dévastateur sur cette jeunesse
donc je milite aussi euh pour aiguiller
ces ces jeunes et leur donner une
nouvelle chance au sein du au sein du
SMA et je suis disposé à à à défendre
cette idée auprès de de notre fonction
de de nos fonctions de parlementaire si
vous
alors non ça non je vous en prie pour ce
qui est de de la nationalité française
et de l'élargissement le cas échant à
des étrangers malheureusement c'est le
code de défense qui gère le SMA et il
faudrait revoir le code de la défense je
pense que c'est pas très simple vous
avez
euh le le sénateur Lurel l'évoquait la
Légion étrangère bon qui n'a pas du tout
le même objectif hein ça fait pas de la
formation professionnelle pour
l'insertion dans la vie active ou alors
ultérieurement non euh c'est c'est
effectivement des questions qui me sont
assez régulièrement posées lorsque je
suis en déplacement très beaucoup plus
souvent d'ailleurs à Mayotte que en
Guyane mais la frontière naturelle qui
est le Maroni ou l'Oyapoc euh fait que
le transfert de population de part et
d'autre euh voilà donc euh aujourd'hui
euh c'est des jeunes Français de 18 à 25
ans si le statut euh si le code de la
défense estchangé on il y aura peut-être
de jeunes étrangers après il y a
d'autres organismes de formation
professionnelle je pense aux apprentis
d'hauteuil en particulier ou alors le
Groupe SOS localement qui aide à à la
formation professionnelle des jeunes à
Mayotte mais ça ne fait pas tout je suis
d'accord au regard du de la pression
démographique en
particulier ferm à maillot avec
les et et je ne suis pas non plus le
préfet de Mayotte qui a dans sa main
quelques régularisation et
naturalisation possible parce que ça ça
existe aussi mais ça n'est pas moi
malheureusement
alors alors sur les épides monsieur le
sénateur service
national alors on a des volontaires
du service national enfin les
volontaires du service civique qui
viennent appuyer en particulier dans la
phase euh de
remédiation sur la partie lire écrire
compté assistant les professeurs de
l'éducation nationale qui sont mis à
disposition euh
auprès de nos formations
administratives les
épides sont peu ou prou des dispositifs
similaires au SMA mais qui s'adresse à
une population plus
jeune dans la phase préalable 16 18
ans de ce que j'en sais dans l'Hexagone
en particulier la population qui vient
dans les épides est encore plus cabossée
par la vie que les jeunes que
j'accueille dans mes formations
administratives alors vous vous évoquez
une continuité c'est pas nécessaire
pourquoi pas mais le niveau enfin là
aussi il faut une certaine cohérence mes
médecins mes psychologues et mes
assistants sociales travaille au profit
déjà d'une population
abîmée
l'effort le transfert enfin ou la
duplication de ce dispositif particulier
qui est propre au service militaire
adapté dans ces épides pourrait
peut-être déjà
déj aider à ce que les jeunes quand ils
en sortent à 18 ans soient mieux armés
parce que effectivement ils suivent une
formation professionnelle et ils ont un
taux d'insertion qui est peu ou pro
similaire à celui du SMA et avec un
travail de fond qui est bien plus
important parce que les jeunes sont bien
plus cabossés alors pourquoi ça n'a pas
été dupliqué dans les territoires
ultramarins je n'en sais rien mais euh
voilà ça c'est je ne sais pas pour pour
ce qui est des jeunes délinquants alors
on a un partenariat particulier avec le
ministère de la Justice qui est un
protocole qui a été d'abord décliné
auprès du service militaire volontaire
et qui a ensuite été signé par le
ministre délégué des outremèes avec la
protection juridique de la
jeunesse où on a un partenariat de
connaissance mutuelle puis de
présentation des filières
professionnelles que nous avons puis
d'une d'un volontariat du jeune qui à la
majorité peut intégrer les régiments à
partir du moment où son casadiier
judiciaire a été blanchi puisqu'il passe
de la minorité à la majorité pas de
crime de sang bien évidemment pas de
trafiquant là aussi
et ayant une population fragile avec
beaucoup de jeunes filles pas de jeunes
dont les faet se rapprocherait à du
harcèlement
[Musique]
ou tout ce qui peut être lié aux
violences faites au f et aux actes
sexuels non
consentis
aujourd'hui j'ai à peu près 8
% de mes jeunes qui viennent dans nos
formations administratives qui sont
originaire de la PGJ et qui ne le disent
pas pour ne pas être
stigmatisé par
ailleurs l'objectif n'est pas non plus
d'être euh
un dispositif qui n'accueille que des
jeunes issus de la PJ parce que bien
évidemment pour nombre de
parents savoir que le régiment ou la
formation administrative est plutôt un
endroit où on retrouve des jeunes issus
ou de jeunes délinquants
ne va pas motiver la famille à orienter
les jeunes vers nos formations
administrative c'est pour ça
que nous essayons de le faire en lien
avec la PGJ sur un certain nombre de cas
particuliers et que ça se fait au fil de
l'eau dans l'année pour éviter que une
promotion ou une cororte de 10 de 12
n'arrive provenant tous de la PG après
le député mesdorf avait
souhaité que nous puissions accueillir
des jeunes dont les peines de prison
pouvaient aller jusqu'à 3
ans c'est difficile de commuer une peine
de prison en formation professionnelle
et d'ailleurs c'est pas mon métier je
n'ai pas de cadre qui soit formé
éducateur spécialisé ou euh euh
responsable de centre pénitentien
donc
tant que ça se fait comme ça l'est
aujourd'hui en bonne
intelligence au regard du contenu du
casier judiciaire parce que j'ai des
jeunes qui ont un casier judiciaire non
effacé et avec lesquels on a de très
très belles réussites donc on ne ferme
pas la porte on ferme la porte à un
certain nombre et on ne souhaite pas
dire on ne souhaite pas que nos
régiments deviennent finalement une
alternative à la peine de prison parce
que on va brouiller le message d'abord
et puis on aura malheureusement par
effet réputationnel forcément moins de
familles qui pousseront leurs enfants en
difficulté à venir chez
nous non je je l'entends parfaitement je
pensais à des à des petits jeunes qui se
vont infliger par exemple des peines
d'intérêts généraux de premiers
avertissement euh qui qui sont train de
glisser vers la délinquence et donc
parfois les familles sont sont débordé
et ne savent plus comment faire elles
sont volontaires mais ne savent plus
comment faire pour les sortir de de ce
milieu vers lequel il tendent avant de
de lever de lever la l'audition de
terminer de clore cette audition donc
j'aimerais encore vous remercier hein le
dispositif et saluer ce dispositif du
RSMA qui a fait ses preuves et qui qui
effectivement est un exemple de de
positif comme l'a dit fort justement
notre collègue t Mohamed I qui est un
dispositif qui a fait toutes ses preuves
et qui peut-être pourrait servir
d'exemple dans nos nos territoires dans
en France hexagonale euh j'ai noté aussi
qu'il faudrait peut-être
entrevoir revoir le code de la de la
défense euh nous allons très
certainement auditionner les ministères
concernés le ministère des armées le
ministère euh de la défense et pourquoi
pas le ministère de la de la justice sur
ces sujets hautement
importants
et parallèlement essayez aussi de lever
votre lever rou de la régulation
générale de la protection des données
qui pourra aussi donner n nous éclairer
un peu plus
sur l'évolution de de ce dispositif au
combien important pour pour nos
territoirees je vous remercie infiniment
et puis nous sommes aussi nous acceptons
les contributions écrites et très bien
alors
donc le le le colonel avnel qui est le
mon assistant militaire a une version
électronique de des propos que j'ai pu
tenir en dehors bien entendu des
questions auxquelles j'ai répondu donc
il vous fera parvenir la version
électronique et puis moi je peux déjà
vous donner ma version papier si vous le
souhaitez voilà elle n'est comme ça vous
et puis je je je vous joins également si
vous le permettez ce que j'appelle le
dialogue de gestion qui est qui est en
fait le bilan sur un certain nombre
d'indicateurs comme le tau d'insertion
des jeunes volontaires le taux
d'insertion des volontaires techniciens
le taux de dénonciation des contrats et
cetera
donc on va vous le on va vous l'adresser
parce que là il y a des données
personnelles donc on on va les on va
blanchir de manière à ce que vous
puissiez avoir les
résultats qui de toute manière seront
communiquer à l'occasion de notre
rapport d'activité voilà merci alors
avant de partir ce qui souhaitent faire
une photo avec
général la solidarité ultramarine
ou